Barack Obama's final State of the Union
address was an unintentional
demonstration of the physics of football
which is to say those goalposts won't
move themselves in 2010 the president
warned that we can't have another Bush
style economic expansion with stagnant
wages and low job growth but after an
even more sluggish Obama recovery the
president is now going after straw men
anyone claiming that America's economy
is in decline is peddling fiction in
2009 Obama said we must address the
growing costs of social security 2016
that's why Social Security and Medicare
are more important than ever we
shouldn't weaken them we should
strengthen them and six years ago the
president said if we don't take
meaningful steps to rein in our debt it
could damage our markets increase the
costs of borrowing and jeopardize our
recovery trillions and trillions of
dollars of debt later as in basically
every single one of his State of the
Union speeches the president vowed to
create green jobs decried hyper
partisanship in Washington and said he
would cut unnecessary regulations wait
who was in charge of regulations in
Washington now and as usual he gave a
ridiculously unreachable task to his
good friend Joe Biden last year Vice
President Biden said that with a new
moon shot America can cure cancer a new
national effort to get it done and
because he's gone to the mat for all of
us on so many issues over the past 40
years I'm putting Joe in charge of
Mission Control
mr. president you're not the only one
with senioritis to be more charitable
there are positive nods toward criminal
justice reform closing Gitmo that we've
heard that song before and about keeping
the national discourse elevated above
Trump Ian levels and though he doesn't
use the word Obama's foreign policy is
more rooted and realism than most the
republican presidential field but even
there the goal posts have been moved and
the rhetoric is still creepy five years
ago Obama was bragging about the lasting
partnership of Iraqi government this
year bupkis unless do you think the war
machine has been ground to a halt grok
this when you come after Americans we go
after you and it may take time but we
have long memories and our reach has no
limits so is there a better way to deal
with this annual exercise and empty
pageantry sure have the president submit
the damn thing in a letter like Thomas
Jefferson used to until then at least we
can rest assured that Barack Obama still
believes us I believe in you the
American people and that's why I stand
here as confident as I have ever been
that the state of our union is strong